[Musica]
chi che sta lottando mentre solo
nell'impostazione a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono vari
generi siamo su un posto proibito che è
un gioco proibito ma noi ce ne sbattiamo
le palle e proviamo giocarci lo stesso
vescovo la chiave della porta di fronte
la trovo né sul tavolo meno male perché
non c'ho voglia di leggere più di quello
però let's go bello allegro meno male
che siamo in un posto così brutto
vediamo se riesco a trovare questa foto
chiave anche se non ho capito neanche
due cose che ha però effettivamente non
ho visto porte ma fa niente bella sta
libreria in the tech ios o dall remember
tanto non leggo chissenefrega
l'obiettivo è uscire ragazzi lo dico io
eccolo qua perfetto de braschi lesbica
non ho nemmeno capito dove dovrebbe
essere st porta che deve aprire la
chiave
ok era questa
e mi va bene quest anno fa minacciandola
dovrebbe poi molto compaq torna da dove
sei venuto l'impulso guardatemi sbarrato
la porta non posso uscire tornare alle
feste venuto tua sorella perché non
posso uscire non posso fare niente e
comunque tutto ciò che è successo
blocca vuoi fare dello shopping a ok ha
già fatto va bene come skyrim pensavo ma
come a ogni volta che esco mi ritrovo
sempre più dentro allora se ne stava per
la va beh sono invitato anche un nano
prima non era così alto soffitto ragazzi
io volevo io vorrei uscire vorrei uscire
posso uscire volendo vorrei uscirne un
posto incazzate perché non è il tuo
capito non unico guarda mi guardi la
videocamera che cosa mi guardi brutto
guardone schifoso vorrei uscire non
posso non posso perché fai schifo
cosa vuoi da me che ci provo volendo la
porta del something in the darkness ii
c'è una mano l'hanno vista la petrini
cadavere andarci a stare non voglio fare
presentazioni adesso voglio stringere
mani che non mi sembra il momento dove
cacchio stimando amica labirinto se va
bene che ci manca solo la beveva c'era
un tizio l'ho visto c'è un tizio mi
prendete per il culo perché
l'ho visto sono un sacco di videocamere
che ti punta non mi sembra ovvio perché
sono bello fotomodello non siamo però il
grande fratello ragazzi quindi no
telecamere grazie le slot c'è un dio non
è proprio un di donare un puntiglio per
persona e para non c'è che hanno un po
di gusti strani provare lo è
saleh cos'è questo non lo so sembra
all'interno di una vagina
però non credo poi non lo so perché c'è
una botola entriamo prima che questo
finisca nei khrin gen
[Musica]
bravo scoreggia anche se di tempo
importante uscire di qua eccoci
something about this room and is natural
ma dai non saranno mica i termosifoni
messi sul soffitto oppure il fatto che
ci sia il portale per l'inferno è stata
né in persona che ci fa da guardia
non è mica quello no ma figurati cosa
vuoi che ci sia di strada snake tablet
sta roba che i sì a snake glock fire
snake fire rock no snake far comodo
michelin for cruisers later pensavo di
dover li cliccare basta invece penso li
mettesse in automatico mire cacchio ne
so io che cacchio ne so se va dai e ma
li mortacci sua due ore su stato non
cliccare lieviti carla sei contenta
lampo flash nand flash è difficile
sorprendersi ancora ma si tanto ormai
guarda guarda ti anche harry potter se
ciao ciao ciao zio timorati anche
reporter serie c che se c'erano cose
simili forme intere unica abbiamo
scoperto leggendo un libro che per
quanto il mortale che per quanto mortale
grazie frate poche volte ho giocato roba
così strana e dove sincero pochissime
volte che è successo
cota fa sono nella spero che sia nel
periodo suo perché sennò è un po strano
c'è un braccio tutto allegro tutto a
posto salve comunque gli importanti li
abbiamo scoperti negli horror ci vanno i
ventilatori col padre che sarebbe utile
è data anche adesso mi farebbe molto
comodo veramente lato c'è un caldo mese
siamo tornati qua non me l'aspettavo
però manca questa porta adesso presento
la c dentro è allegro finalmente sono
tornato alla parte in questione dal da
dove sono entrato è finalmente momento
di tornare a casa è certo qua c'è una
chiave mica per caso braschi let's go
non vedo l'ora di andare a casa ma che
bella casa tua fra the fuck fuck lo dico
io non sbagliano
devo andare così doveva andare così
manuale haicheng jump from here look di
giampà iemma prof
sto vedere cos'è cos'è non ti faccio
telefonare gli sprechi tutto il credito
pronto
l'ho visto in carrefour ha quindi devo
ascoltare quello che vuoi da dirlo è
pronto questo tipo the ringer e capi
meno di just have to have more
subscriber line financing ok rollo dex
figlio del ruolo del no non ne sono
capace andiamo al la parte superiore
non siamo tornati indietro ottimo ecco
questo non me l'aspettavo manco io però
vabbè cinema scacchi madonna che
prodotta zona mi butto de sotto qua
tanto non alternative comunque bello mi
piace che mi devo buttare di sotto ogni
volta per andare a cedere una nuova area
è una cosa che non è che non soffro di
vertigini nei giochi se non sarebbe un
bel problema è che mi sbaglio parti da
lontano solo genera ansia santissimo
gesù orribile
madonna salve sono tornati in via ho
fatto tutto è stato proprio bravo però
non mi fare niente lan tenta quello che
se fosse un tizio che usciva dalla porta
invece non tentano grazie a cosa devo
scrivere qua fratelli ditemelo ditemelo
voi negli scaffali maledetti vita non lo
troverò ei addio addio
oddio oddio no no cacchio che è successo
no no volo mentre il codice guadagnò per
my eyes hai fame servono a enti ordina
di slide play sono uscito ma io lo
metterei volevo mettere la scritta
chissà che cacchio era io faccio un
altro prima che tu mi ammazzino a posto
magari non è finita infatti non è finita
qui bray da letto e ancora di dentro
semplicemente lui pensa di essere uscite
ma si sta rendendo conto che non è così
nella mia trama nella mia testa è questo
il finale di questo profondo gioco
fantastico bravi ragazzi bravi molto
bravi molto bravi molto carini
bellissimo gioco per oliveti sempre
ceduto ragazzi iscrivetevi al mio canale
sono stati riscritti ovviamente era ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video e
la ragazza
[Musica]